to all the main institutions ports roads
checkpoints and never said anything we
just took it over absolutely nobody knew
what to do about it it was actually a
completely new strategic operation where
you basically invade and say you didn't
absolute chaos it had been a very
Russian style attack
the way Russia became involved in the
Ukraine crisis was a indicator of how
they could exert influence Ukraine was a
guinea pig for what they can do
elsewhere be it direct military action
be it media manipulation could it be the
Baltics
could it be any of the old Soviet states
that I'm wanting to go westwards
you have an uprising that starts in here
against the government that was clearly
refusing to follow what appeared to be
the will of the people and that the
alignment of much of Ukraine with
Western thinking following into European
Union was being denied and so they took
to the streets in a very very violent
way freezing the bitter cold weather
standing and fighting against police
special forces who were shooting people
fairly indiscriminately to impose the
will of the government back on which
ultimately their faith
I hadn't seen anything like it Google
sort of many evil in the way who was
being fought
[Music]
the fighting against the fully
weaponized police units at the start
when he first turned up you're trying to
process it that's when you really grasp
actually fine they might be fighting
something here but that has actually
been bodies an and like lost and one of
the arguments that came from both the
government in that was slowly collapsing
and from uh school that they were all
fascists and it was a suraíh twing
conspiracy to turn it into a neo-nazi
state meant exactly that time the
propaganda that came from Moscow which
was they're a bunch of fascists they're
going to come down and take away your
Russian many of whom did speak Russian
in the East they go to burn your
churches they're gonna rape your
children and they are on their way this
hordes coming it was a media controlled
so a load of nonsense but it got more
and more entrenched into the thinking
till in the end the people of Donbass
the East began to think we really are
under attack those rallies started I I
don't think it will burst out into
anything because well usually our region
was stabled Alexander our producer who
was saying to me Stewart this just
doesn't happen and we were saying no it
really is happening this is an uprising
then there was an anti Eastern rally
they arrived in buses and got absolutely
smashed by the Russian support
and then they started taking over
government buildings setting up their
own sort of independent Republic of
Donbass well this is the latest
government building that's been taken
over by the pro-russian militia it's
interesting they wouldn't actually tell
you what they're doing it's quite clear
that they've taken over the offices but
they won't engage at all however they're
quite happy for you to film and I think
that's very much the point of this
they're trying to get over this
propaganda message if you like that they
can take over these type of buildings at
will without doubt Moscow is fueling the
fire control of the media the propaganda
was absolute in the breath their
relations between the eastern Donbass
part of Ukraine and Russia are very very
tight they speak Russian naturally you
know that's what all you saw all you've
heard was Russian speaking Russian flag
it was Russia for me not Ukraine we are
pro-russian we want you know be close to
Russia and I once said that we well
openly that we want to be inside Russia
or something we just want to be close as
an entity they just wanted to have their
own values protected and it sort of like
slowly snowballed into this thing well
actually yeah those are you creating an
army coming we're gonna get attacked yes
that wasn't really why they were coming
they were actually coming to try and
stop the incursion into the country of
Russian soldiers all the time soldiers
wearing green uniforms of Italy men that
we have later to see Crimea they were
already arriving there as well
at the same time only a few hundred
miles away the Russians were actually
taking over Crimea Putin just said I'm
having that back before we even start
anywhere else that's coming back they
just took over the Russian came in and
took over Crimea they dressed completely
different to anyone seen before and they
simply refused to engage with you to
explain they took all the main
institutions ports roads checkpoints
I never said anything they just took it
over but there were pretty serious I
mean you know you'd have to be pretty
stupid ever going absolutely nobody knew
what to do about it certainly no
government in the West and she had never
seen anything like this because it was
actually a completely new strategic
operation where you basically invade and
say you didn't and you continue to say
you're not even though the guys are
Special Forces even to the point where
it's so clear that they are Russian
soldiers they say well then then it just
off-duty Russian soldiers utterly absurd
it was organized it was pre-planned they
were waiting for a time to do it and I
suspect that what Russia wanted to do
was to see what it could do what it
could do to push back it's very very
clever sort of unsubtle but incredibly
subtle at the same time the various
Ukrainian military bases
slowly but surely fell but one was left
there was one base and we decided to go
into the base to have a look this was
very early on in my career you know I
felt like something was gonna happen but
to be honest I had no idea and I said
why aren't they letting us out and
Stewart said we're not going out
I said why he said basically you know
we're in here because we're protecting
them at the moment it was quite clear
something was going on right they were
the last ones and we could see tanks
apcs slowly growing in number troops
kind of all all up on the hills scoping
it out really turned the Stuart and he
said you see that vehicle moving what's
video I'll bet you it just comes through
the wall
I laughed it's you know I'm not joking
so it's pretty pick my camera which says
where am i aiming where I land was it
just aim at that corner is coming
through
it came straight through that straight
through the wall all of the Ukrainian
soldiers put anything they had been
carrying up the floor immediately hands
in the air and everyone all the media
started running around it was absolute
chaos
[Music]
okay these are blast bombs I think
they're coming in the Russians have
stormed the basic they came straight
over to me and tried to push the lens
down they're very aggressive towards us
they didn't want us filming I was
shaking I've never done anything like
this before
the is as scary as health I mean you
know this is happening you know these
are soldiers and you know they're
shooting and my concern was that the
Ukrainian army would actually do
something stupid like try to protect
themselves because they were just gonna
get killed straight away but we could
all get killed with them ultimately when
they come through you put your hands in
the air
and hope they don't shoot you run around
for a bit but when you realize that
wherever you look there's another guy
with a gun pointed at you there's
nothing you could do probably your hands
in the air and say I hope they don't
shoot me but it was a very slick
operation I don't think they were going
in there ready to kill they were just
wanted to overtake and make that point
debaltsevo was really a place that
nobody ever heard of was of no real
value to anyone it was a siding i think
effectively on a massive railway track
but it became a hold a hold out strong
point for ukrainian military as they
were surrounded by a massive number of
Russian banks Gravatt this is a proper
battle fighting everywhere it had been a
very Russian style attack
which is grad missiles just piling in
give up or retreated me
[Music]
there is I hope that the taking of
debaltsevo would lead to a lull in the
fighting in a ceasefire well it doesn't
feel like it here this seems very much
like an army on the move
Ukrainian army eventually got out under
cover of darkness and lost loads of men
I've never seen destruction like it
[Music]
people have been killed as no doubt
about that there were bodies in in
ditches and he could tell very quickly
that this wasn't a mercenary or
russian-backed separatists job
this was a proper job there was a truck
coming up towards me
big big military lorry and as it came up
and passed me I looked behind and the
bloke was just kicking bodies off quite
literally just kicking Ukrainian bodies
off from the Bullock kind of just by my
feet first time I'd ever seen a dead
body so my mouth went to the floor
that's when I kind of grasped yes it was
a small town but Ukraine has probably
put up a hell of a fight
the same truck they've got a guy with a
stomach injury and I took kind of one
that one look at him and it hit he was
dying but they were very quick to put
him on the floor slap him about a bit
and get me over to filming who is this
guy why is he there is he part Ukrainian
forces he is an alleged spy whatever
slap intimidate him everything
sometimes just solo just there it was
hardcore when you're in those situations
if anything we usually get told not to
film but that you know these Russians
wanted to intimidate this bloke they
wanted to embarrass him and I felt bad
you know fine it was great shots and it
told the story but I didn't feel you
know I knew that God didn't really
deserve that he was fighting for
somewhere he probably lived his whole
life
Russia has used Ukraine's differences
between its East and West as a guinea
pig to work out how he can actually do
anything with no obvious solution in
sight whatsoever
I don't see any side willing to make
first step or just somehow resolve the
situation they've never got over NATO
expansion and Putin's ambition is to
make sure that those who used to belong
to the club remain in the club and don't
go and join another one we will become
great again even if it means being
outside of international norms of a
welcomed state even if it takes a decade
you